my question is relating to a debate that
we frequently have in our class which is
the overlap between political advocacy
and philanthropy and I wanted to bring
up something that is back from two
thousand eight the your foundation
awarded french president nicolas sarkozy
with the Foundation's Humanitarian Award
and the reasons for that were quote his
commitment to renew and strengthen
Frances ties to the United States his
steadfast support of Israel and his
global humanitarian efforts I was
wondering if you could elaborate on how
those first two points fit into the
definition of philanthropy in the
relationship between political support
and philanthropic initiatives I think
that's a wonderful question and I will
reiterate I joined the foundation after
that time right so I'm trying to
understand one of the things that's
important is awards and recognition Eric
you were awarded with admission to a
fine University many of you have told me
about other awards and honors and the
like my feeling is an award has multiple
purposes one of which is to recognize
great works that have been achieved the
second is to inspire people to action if
you look at the Wiesel foundation
response after giving this award or
specifically elie wiesel responses to
some of the actions of President Sarkozy
specifically visa V the Roma community I
think that even though an award was
given to someone who's committed to
humanitarian results when he's acting in
a way that the foundation didn't find
consistent with its ethics and values
when he was acting in a way that made us
question pressure resile was comfortable
criticizing so there was actually some
debate about whether some of the actions
happened after the award so the award
was given and much more recently there
were some actions that didn't seem
necessarily consistent
with the values of the foundation and
the board of the foundation and even
though president sarkozy has been a
friend and an ally of the foundation a
variety of humanitarian pro-democracy
inclusive activities when certain
actions in seem consistent professor
reza whole intervened what about even
not just after the giving the present
the award the initial action of giving a
head of state a humanitarian award for
you know philanthropic efforts it's an
ongoing debate and I'm glad that you
raised the question I actually want to
turn around and ask your opinion but I
had this question when I see heads of
state winning awards I have the question
when I see super affluent individuals
receiving humanitarian awards where
sometimes it's interesting to me is it
for the work they're doing they're about
to do or the financial contribution that
someone's hoping to receive and the
Nobel prizes specifically there are
people who have been awarded prizes
where it wasn't obvious to me why that
prize was awarded freepost good deeds or
so I think that Wiesel foundation award
awards are tricky what's your opinion
well I think that any kind of
philanthropic initiative is going to be
infused with the political values and
kind of worldview that that body has I
think it's an interesting question of
you know then the message that it sends
to potential supporters of that
initiative and whether that's inclusive
of you know a wide sector the population
you know and would you know this award
to the president encourage a lot of
people to give to the foundation or not
i think is an interesting topic to
discuss you think it should retreat i
think it will motivate some people to
give and take him well for others